en este vídeo haremos otro ejemplo de
una demostración por inducción y lo que
vamos a hacer ahora es demostrar que
menos 12 más 5 + 8 y así sumamos hasta
el término 13 ene menos 4
esto va a ser igual a n entre 2 que
multiplica a 3 n menos 5 muy bien
entonces como siempre vamos a realizar
el paso base el paso base será cuando en
es igual a 1 entonces qué es lo que
tenemos del lado izquierdo vamos a sumar
desde desde menos 1 hasta el último
término que sería 3 por 1 menos 4 que es
justamente menos 1 entonces en realidad
del lado izquierdo solo tenemos menos 1
y queremos ver si esto es igual a la
formulita de la derecha pero tomando en
e igual a 1 es decir tendremos un medio
que multiplica a 3 menos 5 verdad pero 3
menos 5 es menos 2 y si dividimos entre
2 nos da menos 1 así que podemos
verificar que la igualdad se da para el
paso base muy bien ahora vamos con el
paso de inducción vamos a suponer que la
fórmula
arriba es cierta para un valor n igual
acá es decir vamos a suponer que menos
125 más 8 y así sumamos hasta 3 k menos
4 es igual acá entre 2 que multiplica a
3 k menos 5 lo que vamos a hacer ahora
es demostrar que la fórmula es cierta
para el caso en el que n es igual a 1
que queremos decir con esto bueno que si
sumamos menos 12 más 58 así sumamos
hasta 3 k menos 4 y luego suba sumamos
el siguiente término que sería 3 por acá
más uno menos cuatro verdad queremos
verificar si es cierto que esto es igual
a la fórmula del lado derecho pero con n
igual acá amazon es decir acá más 1
entre 2 que multiplica a 3 por acá más
uno menos 5 entonces lo que vamos a
hacer ahora es justificar que esta
igualdad es cierta entonces lo primero
que hay que hacer es utilizar nuestra
hipótesis de inducción con estos
primeros términos
esta suma por la hipótesis de inducción
es k entre 2 que multiplica a 3 k
5 y luego sumamos el último término el
último término sería 3 por cada 3 menos
4 verdad si desarrollamos el producto
pero 3 menos 4 es menos 1 así que todo
esto sería 3 k menos 1 verdad y queremos
verificar si esto es igual a camas 1
entre 2 que multiplica a 3 k mas 3 menos
5 verdad desarrollando el producto de
adentro pero 3 menos 5 es menos 2 así
que tendríamos 3 k menos 2 como factor
verdad y hay varias formas de ver si
esta igualdad de cierta verdad para mí
quizás lo más fácil es tratar de
desarrollar aunque quizás puede llevar
más pasos verdad así que si
desarrollamos el producto del lado
izquierdo tendríamos 3 acá por acá entre
2 esto nos daría 3 k cuadrado entre 2
menos 5 k entre 2 + 3 k menos 1 verdad y
queremos ver otra vez si esto es igual a
lo que tenemos del lado derecho vamos
atrás
de desarrollarlo esto sería 3 k por acá
más 1 / 2 menos dos por cámaras 1 / 2
verdad simplemente distribuyendo el
producto entonces lo que podemos ver del
lado izquierdo ahora es que 3 acá lo
podemos ver como 6 acá entre 2 verdad es
exactamente igual pero 6 acá entre 2
menos 5 que entre 2 nos da acá entre 2
verdad entonces esto sería 3 k cuadrada
entre 2 más acá entre 2 menos una verdad
y queremos ver si esto es igual a bueno
vamos a tratar de desarrollar este
producto tendríamos 3 k cuadrada entre 2
+ 3 k menos 2 k menos menos 2 entre 2
verdad que es 1 así que veamos si esto
es igual del lado izquierdo tenemos 3 k
cuadrada entre 2 más que entre 2 menos
una verdad y queremos ver si esto es
igual a bueno veamos qué es lo que
tenemos 3 k cuadrada entre 2 y luego
tenemos 3 k entre 2 - 2 k entre 2 eso
nos da más
entre dos y luego tenemos este menos uno
que sobra y podemos verificar que en
efecto la igualdad se da verdad entonces
la expresión que teníamos originalmente
es cierta verdad tenemos la igualdad y
esto quiere decir que pudimos demostrar
digamos este paso de inducción y por lo
tanto la afirmación es cierta